foreign
you've all seen the bombastic headlines
the metaverse is dead
but is it actually true I was certainly
alarmed by the media reporting on the
alleged demise on the industry in which
I'm so involved in so I thought I'd
check in on the metaverse see how it was
doing
the metaverse is very young after all
and we should keep an eye on it
and what I found was that the metaverse
was very much the same metaverse as last
I checked except it had grown bigger and
more impactful
I saw a place where millions of people
who had been financially excluded find
employment and real economic
opportunities
I saw a place where participants either
singly or in groups formed complex
systems that very much resembled the
workings of modern capitalist societies
I saw a place last year that generated
over 30 billion dollars of economic
activity
and had treasuries maintained by those
same communities to the tune of 12
billion dollars
now let's put that a little bit in
context
the metaverse has reserves just below
that of the fiscal reserves of New
Zealand
and greater economic activity than the
GDP of Cyprus
Iceland and a hundred other countries
the murderous seems to be doing okay
but
this may not be quite the metaverse that
you're thinking of
you might be thinking of the metaverse
as this 3D virtual reality immersive
space with additional sensory
stimulation
no what I'm talking about
is the open murderous
powered by web3 and blockchain
the treasuries that I'm referring to are
the treasuries of Taos 12 billion
dollars within control of its
communities without any Central
Authority the banking system underlying
the open meters is defy you might have
heard of decentralized Finance before
but you may not have known that it is
part and parcel of the open metaverse
all of this open metaverse is powered by
blockchain and comprises part of what we
describe as web 3 which we firmly
believe will be the future iteration of
the internet
which is currently still mostly in the
web 2 stage
to access the open metaverse you don't
need fancy VR goggles you just need
plain old boring 2D screens and you can
enter a rich thriving Universe of
capitalist economic societies that have
Virtual Worlds businesses Enterprises
experiences
with millions of digital citizens
Our Lives already have a very strong
virtual component in Asia where I live
we spend over nine hours a day online
that is most of our waking hours and
perhaps for most of us just think about
what it is you do the first thing in the
morning
but in this virtual reality we are like
serfs toiling on the lands of medieval
lords we have no ownership
no rights to speak of
our digital existence
can be removed on any of these platforms
at a moment's notice without any due
process
whenever we are online
we accrue value to networks that don't
belong to us
we are farmed for times attention and
creativity and in so doing generate
large quantities of data and data is the
most valuable of resources for starters
it's powering all of the AI that we've
been hearing so much about
no data
no chat GPT
no self-driving cars
the entire foundation of the AI industry
is built on top of our data
and not just AI every industry covets
our data
data is the new labor
and we're not being fairly compensated
for it
we created but it is exclusively owned
by the Publishers and platforms today
that is a world of web 2 we live in
today but web3 and blockchain can change
that because unlike web 2 we can now
finally have true digital ownership
ownership of things gives us
corresponding economic freedoms
the freedom to transact to do with as we
please
it also allows us to partake in all the
network effects related to the ownership
of these things
think about all the businesses that have
been created just because we own things
such as the cars we have houses we live
in or even the phones ownership also
speaks to our identity
we buy and purchase things because of
what it means to us
self-expression ownership of these
things such as fashion jewelry
and yes even nfts
a lot of people struggle with web 3 and
nfts because they see the prices at the
higher end of things
they look at this board ape and say how
can this be more valuable than this
broken bag which is an actual real item
but people don't buy this broken bag
because they want to put stuff in it
99 of its value
is entirely virtual Network effects
upheld by the community of birkenberg
lovers
who find them the desirable and valuable
its utility is a very distant second
and this is perhaps true for almost
everything that we purchase in the real
world
owning the story
owning a part of the culture being a
part of a community that forms part of
our identity
is why we buy things
the same is true
for the open metaverse
ownership identity culture and community
are far more important considerations
for most of us
than just its utility
and if this still feels far-fetched to
you consider this
last year the video game industry
generated over 100 billion dollars of
sales in Virtual Goods
the fun fact is that all of the things
that they purchased were predominantly
cosmetic and Whimsical in nature
skins trinkets decorative items
things that make your virtual identities
shine
just ask your kids what they want for
their next presence
but everything you purchase in those
worlds in video games today we don't own
that's a hundred billion dollars of
rental Goods
nfts can change that because now we can
actually own these virtual Goods when
you own an nft such as virtual land in
the metaverse you become
stakeholder you become an owner
anytime you own an asset in web 3 it
represents a stake in that Network that
you wish to participate in
imagine every time you shared something
on Instagram for Value you generated you
would receive a small stake in the
network that would be that social
network
think of the open meters
as the construction of new economies and
new societies with a strong Foundation
of digital property rights this presents
us with a remarkable opportunity
to shift away from this current form of
shareholder capitalism
this has left so many people behind
to this newer form of stakeholder
capitalism in which every participant
can now also become an owner
this to me
is what tokenization and web 3 is all
about
that is the meaning of the open
metaverse
tokenization is perhaps also the best
way in which you can protect our digital
intellectual property rights when Gandhi
images sued the creators of stable
diffusion they did so because they could
tell that they were using their images
to train their AI models but they could
only do so because
stable diffusion was sloppy so you could
see the Getty image is Watermark all
over the generated images
most of us won't be so lucky
blockchain can help solve the provenance
of our digital property and lay the
foundation
of protecting our rights
in this web 3 future all of us can get
to earn and own a piece of the equity on
these networks that we construct and
grow
all the data that we generate today
should be paying us an income
and all the other benefits that property
rights may bring
that is why web3 is so often described
as the internet of ownership
and ownership has always been
a key pillar to prosperity
there is a clear correlation
between property rights and The Wealth
of Nations
countries such as Canada and the US that
enjoy strong property rights have very
high gdps high wealth strong
entrepreneurial and capitalist
activities compared to those countries
that have very low property rights that
tend to have low gdps and also tend to
be the poorest in the world countries
with strong profit rights also have
correspondingly much higher freedoms
true digital property rights provides us
with a chance to create a fairer more
inclusive form of capitalism one that
can still provide all the incentives to
help entrepreneurship and Innovation
flourish as capitalism has done for
centuries before
this can already be seen in the digital
context
last year nfts generated over 24 billion
dollars of sales the majority of that
went to the creators and owners of these
nfts web 2 platforms such as Spotify
paid only a third of that to its
creators in that same year
George Washington
famously wrote
freedom and property rights are
inseparable you can't have one without
the other
the same is true for the virtual Realm
in order to ensure our digital Freedom
that we not be slaves to either
platforms or any of the future AIS
we must also have true digital
copyrights thank you
[Applause]